July of 2011 you're gonna see a whole
lot of people moving out yeah welcome to
BBC News special said moonsto humane
city where you could probably that
opening salvo of Operation Iraqi Freedom
my will the work on name her name was
Natalia really yeah I roll the night elf
hunter I didn't realize this gonna be
such a big like everyone's gonna make
fun of you for a while and I had no idea
that like what would happen later on
like what people were like hey what's up
baby and knowing I'm a guy dog whatever
I didn't care I was like fine
when did you start the day of launch oh
really
back in 2004 I was working for NBC at
the time okay
we had just invaded Iraq I had moved to
Killeen Texas and got stationed kind of
on Fort Hood okay which is that I wanted
largest military bases in the country
maybe next to like Fort Bliss or
something it's huge it's like you're
talking about a town of about 125,000
people yeah 57,000 of them work and live
on for it oh wow yeah we'd go in there
and get like a the war report so we're
talking like this like this this DEFCON
room where you're like in there with a
bunch like military leaders and all of a
sudden you're hearing like information
from like General Petraeus and some
other Wow and they're like here's the
update because like they would come in
and talk on the press so I'd be in this
room with a bunch of reporters from like
NBC CNN CBS and and for those who don't
know clean is you [ __ ] like it is
one of the worst places to live on the
planet not much to do no not much to do
it's like the armpit of Texas I [ __ ]
hated it outstanding but I I had it I
was there for six months and so I
remember the day it came out I left work
at 10 o'clock ran right to Walmart
bought a copy of the game and went
directly to my computer at home they
just built and loaded it up and started
playing and I remember like just being
completely consumed by the game I mean I
remember like exploring like Darnassus
like the night of capital and like going
around the island you start off with and
then like just I was I think from like
11:30 to 6:00 a.m. that day I play
non-stop I didn't stop playing and that
was before you could level really
quickly so like it was crazy I remember
like just that was my life for six
months straight
so did you play for the entire six
months the entire six months I mean I
kid you not every single night I played
that game it was my so a lot of people
say like why do you play in the Mo's
like is it an escape like do you like to
meet people for me it was a complete
escape from reality
it was like I I could not think of a
better thing to do with my life than to
just shut off from what was what I was
doing in the real world I remember like
at work I'm just like I would count down
the hours I just look at the clock and
be like okay and then if I wasn't on the
clock I was like I'm like thought bought
another frickin weird place it's like
looking for like quest and all that
other stuff I could find because it
seriously was a break from reality if it
wasn't for a while and the girlfriend
ahead at the time I probably would have
lost my god did mine so yes every day
six months until I moved from Killeen
and Fort Hood I played that game
non-stop and even in six months I did
not even I don't as much as I played I
think I I think I may have got to level
60 after six months but like I just I
just did weird [ __ ] in that game to porn
were like it was more of just like in a
social escape to get the hell out of
that to where I was living and
condiments like a fun little fantasy
world like did